immigration the system that brought you
me but it's still good and I promise
that won't happen again
immigration has been dominating the news
all week long as a caravan of migrants
from Central America continues to head
north and despite it being a thousand
miles and possibly months away Trump has
made it a centerpiece of his closing
arguments heading into the midterms at
this very moment large well organized
caravans of migrants are marching toward
our southern border some people call it
an invasion it's like an invasion a lot
of young men strong men and a lot of men
that maybe we don't want in our country
I don't want them in our country and
women don't want them in our country
women want security men don't want them
in our country but the women do not want
them women want security why young
strong men are invading our country and
coming from our women that is such old
timey racism I'm genuinely amazed that
imogen automatically turned black and
white as he thought like Pleasantville
in Reverse this week Trump has been
threatening immigration actions ranging
from sending 15,000 troops to the border
to ending birthright citizenship and
look it is hard to know what the
president will or even can do going
forward so tonight instead of focusing
on hypotheticals I thought it might be
useful to look backwards at something
he absolutely did do concerning
immigrants family separation it was part
of his zero-tolerance policy where
parents crossing the border were locked
up prosecuted and had their children
taken away the story dominated the news
back in June with distressing images of
kids in cages and shelters milania's
very cool jackets reading I really don't
care to you and of course this moment I
read today about a ten-year-old girl
with Down syndrome who was taken from
her mother and put in a cage I read
about a a they just they won't want to a
ten-year-old with Down syndrome yes he
did
yes Coelho and Taos Key said womp-womp
but and if there is any justice that
will be carved on his gravestone and
when he arrives at the pearly gates the
first thing he'll he all be oh hi Cori
I've been waiting a long time to say
this to you
one put warm
after a national outcry and court
challenges the President signed an order
reversing course and the story kind of
faded from the headlines but it is
really worth revisiting because a number
of government reports recently came out
giving us a much clearer picture of what
was actually happening and while it
seemed malicious and chaotic at the time
at every step it was even worse than you
might assume so let's look at two major
aspects of family separation how it was
done and why and it starts with the how
because you may remember heartbreaking
stories of parents unsure where their
children had been taken but when Alex SR
Secretary of Health and Human Services
was asked about this he reassured
everyone that there was nothing to worry
about there is no reason why any parent
would not know where their child is
located I could at the stroke of ethic
at keystrokes I've sat on the ORR portal
with sit with just basic keystrokes
within seconds could find any child in
our care for any parent you know it's
not every day that you see a man testify
with the goal of convincing people he
has access to a lot of kids on his
computer
seriously guys just a few taps on the
old keyboard and it's kid City on this
thing pretty much the second I open my
computer boob I'm up to my neck in
children and yes I heard how that sounds
and you know what I like it well I saw
may have known where the kids in his
custody were that was only one piece of
the puzzle the critical information that
allowed kids to be matched with parents
was compiled by a different Department
Homeland Security and an Inspector
General report found that their data was
not just incomplete and inconsistent but
that each step of this process was
vulnerable to human error increasing the
risk that a child could be lost in the
system which is terrible you should be
able to lose children in a government
system as easily as in a chuck-e-cheese
ball pit I'm sorry we're gonna have to
call off the search mrs. Donaldson
Ralphie's loss to the balls now
in fact what we've been told that the
government separated around 2600
children and around 220 kids are still
being held away from their parents we
actually can't say for sure whether
either of those numbers are accurate
just two weeks ago the government
apparently found 14 more children and
added them to Italian just think about
that 14 children were missing and we
didn't even know it how was that not a
bigger story when those 12 boys were
stuck in a cave in Thailand there were
live cameras and Elon Musk was sending
submersibles and calling rescuers
pedophiles now I'm not saying that's
what I wanted to happen here I didn't
want it to happen then but at least
people are paying attention and
all this incompetence should have been
obvious because when nonprofits tried to
check on the kids the government often
didn't have a good system to locate
those that were listed as being present
we were given a list by the government
and we were told that we could choose
who we wanted to speak to looking
through the list of over 500 names I
noticed that there were some very young
children there including a two-year-old
several one year olds and one child that
was listed as being zero so I asked to
see those children they left and came
back and said that they couldn't find
the children they said to me what we
called out their name and nobody
responded so we don't know where they
are so I sort of said their babies their
babies obviously they're not gonna
respond to their name being called okay
anyone who calls a babies name and then
gives up on finding them either knows
nothing about babies or is covering for
a baby who doesn't actually want to be
reached sorry
so it just tell them I'm not in today
I'm Optima diaper and triangles over
here I've got a 2:30 meeting with my
young toes to prep for Mondays I'm all
right seriously am i right I don't know
the days of the week I am after all a
baby and even with even with the
help of nonprofits in locating and
reuniting parents hundreds of whom
incidentally were actually deported
without their children the government
still had fuck-ups like when one mother
who'd had her five month old
breastfeeding baby taken away was later
handed back the wrong baby and just to
imagine thinking you're about to be
reunited with your child after being
forced apart
and being given someone else's shitty
baby I'd say this as a parents my infant
is a miracle and a joy anyone else's is
a charmless snots monster get it away
from me
so to put it mildly when it comes to how
did we do this the answer seems to be a
combination of incompetently and cruelly
which brings us to the other big
question why why did we do this well so
many Trump administration argue that
they simply had no choice are you
intending for this to play out as it is
playing out are you intending for
parents to be separated from their
children are you intending to send a
message I find that offensive no because
what why would I ever create a policy
that purposely does that no no a
deterrent I would never you offend me
sir here's the thing about this
administration you can always tell you
figured out exactly what they're doing
when they get offended by your
description of what they might be doing
it's a pretty obvious tone he's like a
poker player ejaculating every time they
have a good hand okay I think we all see
what's happening here
now often the official line was that
family separations were not a deterrent
they were simply a consequence of having
to enforce the law as the then acting
head of ice
Thomas Holman explained at the time
every law enforcement agency in this
country separates parents from children
when they're arrested for a crime we are
a law enforcement agency we are
enforcing the criminal laws I don't
blame anybody want to be the greatest
country in there at being a part of this
greatest country on earth which we all
are but there are a white way to do it
there's a wrong way to do it okay it's
pretty hard to listen to someone say
with the greatest country on Earth while
simultaneously justifying why we're
unnecessarily ripping kids away from
their parents especially when that
person looks like what would happen if a
kind of monster energy drink John
Lithgow but a few things there regarding
the right way because first many of
these people were applying for asylum
meaning they're seeking protection from
persecution and under international and
US law it is legal to apply for that no
matter how you enter the country second
while the Trump administration insisted
that the right way for solemn seekers to
come in was through a port of entry like
an official border crossing they made it
far
more difficult to do that with many be
repeatedly denied entry into the country
and forced to wait days or even weeks
and you can't just arbitrarily delay
people that long
there are solemn seekers looking for
safety not AT&T customers trying to
speak to a representative that's right
no finally finally crossing the border
in the wrong way is actually only a
misdemeanor on first offense in fact
most people are usually just sentenced
to time served and that's the thingy
contrary to what you might think most of
the parents who were separated from
their kids were charged to plead guilty
and serve their sentence all fairly
quickly now in the past we generally
didn't prosecute parents and even let
many of them go free awaiting their
immigration hearing which makes sense so
why did we suddenly start keeping people
who had already served their time locked
up and away from their kids
well because Trump hated the old system
he called it catch and release and he
described it in wildly misleading terms
we catch a criminal a real criminal a
rough tough criminal we take his name
and then we release him and we say
please show up to court in a couple of
months you know what the chances of
getting up the quarter leg zero okay now
deep down when Trump said the number
zero you just instinctively knew that no
matter what the number was it was
definitely not zero right because if he
says something's hot it's cold
if he says something's up it's down if
he said this is a cute puppy you'd
automatically think I'm not sure why or
how but that puppy is definitely a
and when it comes to family seeking
asylum who remember were the ones
largely impacted by family separation
the number is ridiculously far from zero
because 96% of them turned up to court
after being released from detention and
under Obama administration program
called family case management where each
family was assigned a case manager who
then helped them navigate the system
99.3% attended their hearing so Trump
was wrong he was 99.3% wrong and you
know what that means
you probably expecting the tiger to come
out now but sadly he died of sadness
several months ago so all this but now
does is increase my morphine drip so it
just numbs the pain it's not perfect but
it helps see you later now Trump
discontinued that case management
program despite the fact that even ice
called it an overall success and went
with ripping families apart instead so
for the final time why if they'd already
paid the price for their crime and there
were other better ways to ensure that
they showed up for court why the
everlasting did we really do this
well I would argue that this is the
logical result of a general hard right
turn toward demonizing immigrants for
political advantage in a way that some
might call racist and others would be
wrong about now conservative immigration
arguments essentially now follow a
pretty clear pattern crossing the border
is a crime therefore anyone crossing it
is a criminal and since all criminals
are dangerous anyone crossing the border
is a dangerous criminal never mind the
fact that immigrants are less likely to
commit crimes than people born here that
has simply not stopped Republicans from
running toxic anti-immigrant anti
caravan political ads like these a young
woman gunned down by an illegal
immigrant who should have been deported
illegal aliens invade America Democrats
who stand in our way will be complicit
in every murder committed
by illegal immigrants Mexican drug lords
ms-13 gang members sex traffickers ms-13
violent gang members gang members known
criminals people from the Middle East oh
you know that's racist because they just
gave up any pretense of specific
fear-mongering and simply said people
from the Middle East at that point why
not go all in and just start naming
groups you hate the caravan also
contains Planned Parenthood gays who
want wedding cakes black Santa and a
thirty-foot Nancy Pelosi Democrats will
be complicit in every person the giant
Pelosi is and if you watch enough of
those ads you realize it's not that they
don't want immigrants to come here
because they're criminals is that
they're calling them criminals because
they don't want them to come here and to
see that in action
just watch this exchange that CNN had
with a New Jersey Trump supporter so
you're worried about immigration only
coming in the illegal way not the legal
way come in the legal way and you are
more than welcome I mean it is legal to
seek asylum well I hope Trump changes
that you don't want any asylum seekers
no no it's simply not often that you see
someone's cover story fall apart with so
little are you three kids wearing
a trench coat no do you want some ice
cream yes there are three of us and we
all like chocolates we're we're now so
accustomed to see immigrants as a threat
the politicians routinely talk about
them in the language of war remember
Trump referred to the caravan as an
invasion and sent troops to the border
and that kind of militaristic talk can
make people think that it is necessary
to make the kind of impossible choices
made during a war which is how things
like family separation happen just
watches Jessica Vaughn of an
anti-immigration think-tank tries to
justify what we did a lot of Americans
find it appalling what do you say to
them I think it's appalling that we have
to do it what do you think the
consequences are for these children that
have gone
that are still going through this trauma
I think it's very possible that some of
these kids war will have some lasting
effects right
but lasting damage to children is a huge
consequence you're separating them from
their parents not telling them you ate
all their Halloween candy to get on
Jimmy Kimmel while we're on that
topic know what to do that I mean I'm
really glad that some people do because
it's extremely funny but nobody should
but please keep doing it and while she
acknowledges that what we're doing is
appalling she says we have to do it but
the truth is we don't we don't have to
do any of it because even though the
language of war is being used there is
not a war and the only reason people
keep talking like there is one is to
give themselves permission to make the
choices they want to be forced to make
but family separation cannot be one of
them because as she says these kids will
have some lasting effects but what
that's easy to say in the context of
abstract pediatric science the reality
of it is heartbreaking take
Henry he's a six-year-old from Honduras
he was separated from his mother and
reunited after a month apart but as a
documentary crew found their ordeal was
far from over and I'm warning you this
is going to be rough to watch
[Music]
the Colosseum formerly artemiy who had
come down mucho somewhere get hurt we
who ya knows wait to eHome yeah we did
that and not because we had to but
because we chose to and horrific ly we
may actually be about to do it again
Trump has publicly 30 with bringing back
family separation and Thomas home and
supported that idea during a recent
interview with Fox & Friends
or as it's not in the business a
face-to-face meeting with the president
well let me talk about the
zero-tolerance policy that was the right
thing to do regardless how sad and
unfortunate no one was he family
separated but when they separated those
people that were prosecuted into the
country illegally the numbers went down
22% in just two weeks if they would have
stuck with that for 30 60 days there
wouldn't be a caravan today
yeah maybe Tom and you know what if we
surrounded the border with randomly
firing flamethrowers and snakes that we
tried to stand up whenever anyone
approached that could potentially drive
the caravan away to but we don't do
things like that cuz it's not supposed
to be who we are
and painfully aware for this Trump
here's that idea coming out of a
television he may well go someone write
that down
snakes and flamethrowers that's a great
idea I had it that's my idea so look
look if the president really wants to
make Tuesdays in election about him and
about immigration
then then fine let's make it about that
because family separation is perhaps the
most emblematic moment of his presidency
so far it was cruel sloppy needless
racist and ultimately exactly what we
should have expected and I would argue
the biggest threat to our status as the
greatest nation on earth is not a
caravan a thousand miles south of us
it's whoever thinks that doing this is
an acceptable response
you